[Musique]
selon la définition du petit larousse
les cheminées sont les conduits de tôle
ou de maçonnerie par où s'échappe la
fumée cette définition laconique ne dit
pas toute une nuit par an en effet les
cheminées ont une autre destination
cette nuit là elles deviennent par une
mystérieuse inversion le déversoir du
ciel et leur but essentiel n'est plus
que de faire arriver au soulier placé
devant l'âtre les cadeaux du père noël
[Musique]
autrefois est souvent encore dans nos
campagnes tout était simple les
cheminées où l'on mettait fumée les
jambons posséder des conduits d'air tiko
est d'une taille qui permettait le
passage d'une brouille
[Musique]
aujourd'hui par contre quelle différence
le peuple des chemines y est infiniment
divers étroite coude et zigzaguant
innombrables elle pour chacune leurs
problèmes et c'est cela qui complique la
tâche du père noël
il lui a donc fallu mettre à jour un
recensement d'un nouveau genre procéder
à l'étude de chaque cas disposer de
services spécialisés dont l'aspect ni
l'outillage n'appelle l'attention à
défaut d'être invisible et c'est sur ce
problème des cheminées que les
actualités françaises ont réussi à faire
interviewer le père noël par le plus
indiqué de leurs enquêteurs par les
lions des maniaques qui lisait pour
faire arriver les jouets dans les
souliers de l'objet est inférieur aux 10
mai de la chine et ses treize tonnes est
le principe qui s'applique à la chute
des corps tout cas ils présentèrent
maison c'est aussi qu'il possède une
énergie tel qu'il risque de se briser
il faut dont le freiner dans sa chute
problème du retour du spoutnik soit à
l'aide d'une fusée retard d'athris se
joue entre en sens contraire
soit à l'aide d'un parachute
ralentisseurs ces deux moyens ont été
l'objet d'études très poussée
[Musique]
c'est cependant une troisième formule
qui a été choisi elle avait depuis
longtemps fait ses preuves
[Musique]
il arrive sans doute mais une fois sur
vinyle plus le filet car ce qui explique
que les soldats de plomb compte parfois
des invalides
[Musique]
il ya aussi d'autres cas le plus ardu et
celui du gabach dont le cerceau et
l'exemple pour le résoudre les services
du père noël ont mis au point un liquide
astringent d'une formule gardée secrète
mais d'une efficacité absolue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
quelques coups de vaporisateurs et les
molécules se resserre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'arrivée et la chaleur aidant le
cerceau reprendra ses dimensions
il faut tout de même compter avec les
stocks d'astringence leurs défauts
expliquent l'arrivée imprévue d'un petit
larousse d'une boîte de compass ou d'une
petite soeur et il faut compter aussi
avec les erreurs de doses
penser c'est l'immensité du problème
quand votre regard se porte sur les
toits posez vous la question ce
réparateur ce ramoneur sont-ils vrai est
ce qu'il ne serait pas plutôt des
collaborateurs du père noël
la tête
[Musique]